les touristes affluent au centre ville
de Montréal et sont nombreux à profiter
de long week-end comme ce couple de
Boston aux États-Unis leur dit ces jours
des présidents sans quoi il n'aurait pas
pu explorer cette nouvelle ville
du New Jersey février est un bon mois
pour un congé selon elle
son conjoint indique le Québec devrait y
voir c'est torontoise qui est venu
visiter des amis à Montréal abondent
dans le même sens je pense que on a
besoin un jour pour les familles ici
aussi le jour de la famille est
officialisé en Ontario en Alberta en
Colombie-Britannique au
Nouveau-Brunswick et en Saskatchewan
bien des gens aimeraient que ce soit
aussi le cas au Québec
calendrier là c'est férié partout et on
travaille donc c'est pas vraiment juste
je pense que ouais ça devrait être férié
du Québec François Legault indiqué qu'il
était contre la joue d'un congé plus
récemment à la suite de la mort de la
reine mais aussi en 2021 alors que le
fédéral a institué un congé pour la
Journée nationale de vérité et de
réconciliation par voie de communiquer
l'équipe du ministre du Travail Jean
Boulet écrit nous analysons pas la joue
de journée fériés additionnelle
actuellement selon Québec ajouter un
férié coûterait trop cher plus de 700
millions de dollars par an selon la
Fédération canadienne de l'entreprise
indépendante qui privilégie le
statuts sur l'économie du Québec on
évaluer que c'était environ ça coûtait
environ 3,6 millions à l'échelle
canadienne certains travailleurs de
l'Île du Prince-Édouard seront aussi en
congé lundi pour la fête des insulaires
tandis que Manitoba c'est le jour de
Louis-Riel en l'honneur de celui qui a
mené la résistance des métis
une reconnaissance du travail que
Louis-Riel a fait pour les bêtises
francophones
et sa communauté au Québec la loi
prévoit huit jours fériés par année
alors qu'un Ontario il y en a 9 ici
Frédéric pépère Radio-Canada Montréal